- With animation, I know that you don't,
'cause I've done animation as well,
so you don't get to actually
see the costars a lot of times,
but how cool was it to
work with Dwayne Johnson?
Like, y'all saw each
other a bit, obviously,
so how cool was that?
- Yeah, it was wonderful.
I actually met him after the
recording was all finished.
We met at a press junket,
and I was finally able to
put the voice to the face.
And he's massive, and
plays this amazing Maui,
who's a bigger than
life character, so well.
He's kind, he gives great
hugs, he smells good.
My mom has a joke that
when she first met him,
she went rock climbing,
so there's also that.
(Kelly laughing)
All around.
- Oh my god, I love your mom. (laughing)
- It was an experience.
- [Kelly] That's a great joke.